All right, you were able to come up with a meal
that can feed a family of four-
Of four
For under $20.
Absolutely, so the meal that we're preparing today
is actually gonna be a yogurt marinated chicken.
It's a grilled chicken.
And it also comes with a ton of vegetables.
It has red onion, it has broccoli.
So I know health was a concern also.
So there's a lot of healthy stuff going on.
And then it comes with a side salad,
a grilled romaine, with cucumbers,
and more red onion and avocados.
So something nice and fresh.
And all of that came to grand total of $19.83.
(audience cheering)
You can go on our website at the drewbarrymoreshow.com
and get that exact list.
I love that it's written out, that's super organized,
and I don't have to remember stuff,
that gets me all nervous.
Okay, so Sherry and fam,
the first tip that I have when you're really trying to
keep things more affordable,
the spice rack is your friend.
So here we have all these wonderful spices.
We have paprika and cumin and turmeric and some chili flake.
And then we're also gonna use some yogurt for the marinade.
But, the second tip is when you're developing recipes
or when you're thinking of cooking something
you wanna use the ingredients in multiple ways
so that you get like more bang for your buck.
So in this recipe, we're gonna have it in as a marinade.
And then it's gonna show up a little later as a dressing
for our salad.
And Drew, I know sometimes people don't wanna do chicken,
you can also substitute
for a really beautiful cauliflower steak.
I will represent the vegetarians.
The vegetarians, equally, equally delicious.
We're gonna also grate some garlic into this.
And then you know me, I love cilantro stems.
Use the cilantro stems for the marinade.
Use the leaves for the garnish and the salad.
That way you're really maximizing all your ingredients.
Just gonna mix that in.
We're gonna do a little bit of limes zest, excuse me,
as well.
And then we're gonna loosen it up with
a little bit of olive oil.
And then the last optional ingredient,
I know you love this, is a little bit of hot sauce.
I'm also missing-
As soon as you get that nice and mixed,
you're basically going to, where's my tongs?
You're gonna marinate the chicken in that.
And now we have a very hot grilled pan.
To that marinade, you're also putting the vegetables, right?
So I'm gonna put the chicken down
to make more space for the vegetables.
Woohoo, nice and sizzly.
Okay, so I also added to the bowl, the marinated broccoli.
What about the onion?
And the red onion as well, absolutely.
So that's all going down.
This chicken filled marinade is gonna go,
it's starting to smell really good, right, Sherry?
You're nodding over there.
I'm gonna put this aside.
And after you start grilling,
you're basically gonna pop it in the oven.
So it goes in the oven at 425,
for about 15 to 20 minutes, until the chicken, obviously,
or the cauliflower, is fully cooked through.
Drew, you okay?
(audience laughing)
All right, you got this.
Teamwork.
Yes, be gone.
(audience cheering)
Look how good that looks.
I'm helping you out
over here.
You usually do.
You're the one who saves me.
That's a little bit of a hot pan.
All right, thank you, it looks good, it looks cooked.
Okay, so that just came out of the oven.
In the meanwhile, we also have a grilled romaine salad.
So I love grilled romaine.
I don't know if you guys have ever had grilled romaine.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
Grill the lettuce a little bit,
because that gives it a little sweetness,
a little nuttiness,
but then the other leaves, the outer leaves remain crunchy.
So it's just like a little update on your romaine salad.
We have all this fresh avocado, cucumbers as well.
And then the last thing we're gonna do, actually,
is make the dressing.
So the other half of the yogurt that we used earlier,
gets saved for the dressing.
And this is just yogurt, a little water to thin it out
and to stretch the ingredients.
Really?
Yogurt with water.
Just a little bit, and then the cilantro leaves
from the cilantro stems earlier.
And I'm gonna plate it a little.
I put the sauce on top?
Yes, so you're gonna put your cauliflower on your plate
and put the sauce on top.
All right, I would love
for you guys to start serving yourselves as well.
This is all about you.
You wouldn't know it with my shenanigans, but it is.
This looks beautiful.
Is anyone going for the cauliflower
or are you all doing the chicken?
I'm trying some of the cauliflower.
Oh, good.
I am gonna join you in trying the cauliflower.
Okay, ready, set. oh, you're going, perfect.
Sorry.
Okay, I'm going in.
It smells so good.
That's delicious.
(audience cheering)
Well, and you and I like the spice and the flavors.
Forget them, we're twins, you and I are twins.
I would love to be your twin any day.
Sherry, what do you think?
I love it,
I love that the cauliflower has flavor to it.
Usually you think cauliflower
and it's like mush or you know, flavorless,
but the crust on that is really good.
The spice crust is your friend.
So go visit your spice cabinet, start reaching in there.
Ladies, what do you think?
This might make me like spicy food.
Yes.
(upbeat music)